we are in Miami for Super Bowl 50 for
just six days away the Kansas City
Chiefs hosting air quotes hosting the
San Francisco 49ers the Chiefs are the
home team first time in the Superbowl
for them in 50 years 50 years for the
Tracy long time coming and this isn't
one of those teams that kind of like the
AFC's version of the Vikings where
they're relevant they contend right they
knock on the door but there's always
something there's always something and
now they got something in Patrick
mahomes I heard up with Andy Reed who
because I compared them more to the
Packers more than I don't know why
there's got four trophies I will they
have a trophy one yes I think it's more
at some levels yeah more frustrating to
be on the porch and unable to kick the
door in than to be out in the weeds and
the bushes unable to even find the
stairs to the porch like teams like the
Browns and the line I think it is more
frustrating I do agree with that yeah
when you keep getting close and close
it's just like a little bit of torture
that way to where yeah there's a lot of
other teams who don't even get to get
tortured by their team being in the
playoffs and you can come to terms with
it a lot easier but it is one of the
like iconic franchises to your point and
for them to be 50 years in between Super
Bowls because they travel I mean they
travel like a Green Bay Packer fan base
I mean it's it's truly a special place
when you go into Arrowhead so you know
the state of this this whole city is
gonna be red and yellow I know you know
they are they are I know I know
different shade of red with a little
gold splash so you've got Andy Reed
who's been coaching for twenty years now
he is 16 years between Super Bowl
appearances he has continuously coached
the entire time the Eagles and then the
Kansas City Chiefs and you've got
Patrick mahomes second year as a starter
parallels to Dan Marino you know on the
49ers side you got parallels from Jimmy
Garoppolo to Bob Griese cuz he hasn't
been throwing much on the Chiefs side
it's parallels between Patrick mahomes
and Dan Marino the young gunslinger the
guy who's revolutionising the game
getting an early shot to set his legacy
right and the lesson from Dan Marino is
and we're gonna have him on set later
this week and I'm sure he gets asked
about this far more than you'd like to
talk about it or when you get to the
Super Bowl that early you just assume
you're going
back yeah and then again and again and
he never got back no never got back and
you know uh you know I think first thing
to just to hit on this just the Andy
Reid thing you talked about to me I
always look at it and still go the the
parallels between Dick Vermeil are
amazing I mean the fact that they
started off in Philadelphia
you know Dick Vermeil got with the Rams
he got with a special quarterback in a
special offense and here's Andy Reid
with a you know special quarterback in a
special offense but to like the mahomes
pointer Green wasn't that special no but
I you know Kurt Winery yes but but to
your mahomes point like III can't state
how big this week is really I mean where
does mahomes career go this is gonna be
a defining moment I mean is he gonna go
into Dan Marino ville is he gonna go
into John Elway Ville where it's just
gonna be a constant fight to try to win
one is it gonna be the start of oh watch
out he won and now it's only year two of
him starting and now he's got a chance
to become a three or four times Super
Bowl champion I mean there is a lot at
stake for Patrick mahomes as far as his
career and legacy just this week I think
that's what's fascinating about it and
yet all the parallels between you know
Marino and us being here in Miami is
fascinating anybody's excuse you that's
thank you thank you for I was trying to
do that as subtly that's okay I'm still
trying to beat this cold yeah I think I
have it almost beat you better beat it
I'm gonna give it to you yeah thank you
I know you are thank so the thing about
my homes because it's not in a vacuum
there's always an opponent and he's
facing a pretty formidable opponent
that's the problem there's only so much
of this game he can control and if
you've got this 49ers meat-grinder
offense that's gonna be able to run the
ball run the ball run the ball around
the ball it doesn't matter what my homes
can do right right it's gonna be alright
the 49ers chew up a bunch of clock and
they're gonna score their points and now
hey Patrick gets on you do go out there
and make it happen and the one thing
we've seen from the chiefs and their two
playoff wins slow starts yes they afford
to have a slow start you know whether
it's the scripted plays whether it's the
extra practice in preparation they
cannot afford to fall behind the way
they fell behind 24 to the Texans ten
points twice to the Titans right nothing
in 17-7 you can't let yourself try to do
that again because number one third time
may not be a charm yeah and number two
49ers gonna be a much tougher
team to come back against then the
Texans are the type much better I mean
let's let's not even like let's not even
try to confuse that conversation the
49ers are in a different stratosphere
than the Titans or the Texans their
defenses
you know the Titans past defense was
what 26 and football something like that
you know this San Francisco 49ers
defense has everything and to your point
Mike I mean you're a hundred percent
right you give them a ten nothing lead a
seventeen nothing lead with these pass
rushers and now they can drop back into
coverage I don't know I don't think my
homes will be able to pull off that type
of magic now you know the big thing is -
what you said with the 49ers give them
that slow death run game
you know the 49ers traditionally are not
really a slow death run team that way
anyway so we'll see but you know they
they usually end up gashing you for 20
and 30 yard runs now they do control the
clock I get all of that but I do think
Andy Reid and Spagnuolo they're gonna
have to have a failsafe plan and again a
little bit to what we talked about early
in the year where it's gonna be crap or
get off the pot like okay they can
explain that I'm not familiar with that
phrase well I'm you know I I know I'm
gonna go football wise though just so
people understand what I'm saying what I
mean by that is it's like okay the 49ers
have driven down on the first drive of
the the game and it's a 10 play 80-yard
Drive and they true up seven minutes
o'clock the next time the 49ers get the
ball like Kansas City can't afford to
play that game again so they're gonna
have to make something happen whether
you want to blitz run blitz take a
chance whatever it may be either they
score fast or you get back on the field
but I do think that is a real thing in
this game because mahomes can't be
sitting over there by the gatorade
bottle too long that was a theme that
you pushed early in the year when the
Kansas City Chiefs were willing but I
let defense's chew up time chew up clock
and not force the issue yeah your point
is force the issue
they either score right or they have a
turnover right either way our offense is
not in mothballs right they gotta have
like maybe it doesn't work out that way
maybe they're both going back and forth
and you don't have to play that way but
yes you gotta have that I think in the
back of your mind to make sure that the
strength of your team the money on your
team your team was built around mahomes
Watkins Hill Kelsea offensive line Andy
Reid that's what the Kansas City Chiefs
are that's where their money is and
that's the talent that got them here so
you don't want that
being a non-factor on the sidelines for
you know half the football game let me
ask you this because there's a
presumption as it relates to the 49ers
offense which we'll be talking about
more coming up that if they can run the
ball we'll know it early
well no it's unstoppable and it's not
like it's gonna change right can we say
the same thing about the Chiefs offense
though no if they're able to let me let
me know what I'm telling you now yeah if
if they're able early on right so flood
zones and Tyree Keogh and Sammy Watkins
Travis Kelce DeMarcus Robinson Michal
Hardman if they are able to overpower
the secondary and patrick holmes is able
to buy enough time with his legs yeah
behind the line of scrimmage to find
open guys will we know early that hey
it's gonna be 34 37 points from the
chiefs good luck keeping up well I don't
know if you will you know you know but
these type of games is Super Bowl it
only takes one or two plays to jumpstart
things to where all the sudden you go
like I'll still remember hey New England
Patriots Carolina Panthers right it was
this slow game for what three quarters
three as soon as it was scoreless late
in the first half right and all Helper
and then all huh it just took a few big
pass plays in the third quarter and all
the sudden we were like wait it was a
defensive struggle in the first half and
now we're in a shootout in the second
half so I think you know it can go
either way here with that because
there's a ton of talent and explosive
players on both sides of the football
field I don't know if it's necessarily
something I feel like my homes in the
Kansas City offense can just about
overcome anything at this point I guess
is where I want to say to you if they
get off to a slow start
I don't think they're gonna panic as
they proven to us and I do think they
could come out on fire and go right down
the field as well that's my point if
they come out right working right out of
the gate right can the 49ers stop it can
they adjust because I don't think that
the Chiefs defense can enjoy if they
just can't stop the 49ers game sure
that's that sure my point is if the
Chiefs are coming out and that passing
game is working well the 49ers to be
able to adjust or will it just be hey
you know what they finally stepped into
a matchup yeah where it doesn't favor
them their secondary isn't good enough
and you cover all those guys yeah and
therefore can't get to Patrick my home's
quickly enough it's just not it's just
not a good four yeah I think I think it
- what you're saying right there if they
come out like that then it's gonna be a
shootout yeah I guess it will dictate
the game I think
yeah yeah I know sorry well it's it's
early and then I cut you off a lot but I
do think that yes if they get off to
that type of start that it just opens up
the the floodgates for Andy Reid to have
no fear formations plays whatever it may
be and then also think as a defense in
those situations Mike you're like well
they're on fire everything's coming out
of from all different directions here
it's Kelsey it's Hill it's Watkins I
don't know what to expect and then
Reid's had two weeks a game plan then if
it starts out like that I would expect
it to be a real high-scoring affair the
thing about the Superbowl you do have to
basically expect the unexpected who
would have dreamed last year that the
Patriots and the Rams would combine for
16 right you just lock in and let it
unfold and we spent that's the beauty of
it we're gonna spend the whole week
trying to figure out what's gonna happen
and then at some point we're just gonna
turn it on see what happens and see what
happens that will not happen this year
thirteen to three yeah I think I feel
pretty good about that I do you might
you mentioned that Superbowl 38 yeah the
Panthers Patriots right from February 1
2004 16 years ago right no points scored
by either team in the first quarter
right 24 total points in the second
quarter okay no points scored in the
third quarter Wow 37 total points scored
holy cow I didn't realize the third had
no points either that's it's
unbelievable so yeah it just shows you
you know with two great teams and a game
where it's you know win or go home to be
the champion whatever it may be people
panic on the defensive side of the ball
whatever it is about offensive
coordinators pushing the envelope you
can exceed explosions of points like
that and this one feels so evenly
matched like it's hard to get a feel for
where it's gonna go but I accept points
right I mean like I think the lowest I'm
thinking is like 28 24 right I don't
maybe it's a 38 35 but I'm thinking like
Louis is 2824
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports